so you mentioned simulation
this is super interesting to me and and
this perhaps could be a super dumb
question but
no i just think i'm gonna prove you
wrong on that one
you simulate molecules to understand how
they look from a distance is what i
understand like what does that
simulation
look like so it's uh it's talking about
the the which colors that the rainbow
will be missing is that
the goal of the simulation that's a goal
but it's really just a very
very nasty schrodinger's equation so
it's a quantum
simulation it's simulating at the
quantum level yes so i'm a quantum astro
chemist
hi i'm clara i'm a quantum astrochemist
how we should have started this
conversation
can you describe the three components of
that
quantum astro and chemist and how they
interplay together
so i study the quantum behavior of
molecules hence the quantum and the
chemist
specifically so i can detect them in
space and see
astro so what i what i do is i figure
out the
probability of a molecule being in a
particular state
there's no deterministic nature to the
work i do it so it's
every transition is just a likelihood
but if you get a population of that
molecule it will always happened
and so this is all of the quantum level
it's a stronger equation
on i think 27 dimensions i don't
remember it by hard
and what this means is i'm solving these
giant
quantum matrices and that's why you need
a lot of computer power
giant computers to diagonalize these
enormous matrices
each of whom describes a single
vibrational behavior of a molecule
so i think phosphine has 17.5 million
possible states it can exist in
and transitions can occur between pairs
of these states
and there's a certain likelihood that
they'll happen this is the quantum world
nothing is
deterministic there's just a likelihood
that all jump from one state to another
and these jumps they're transitions
and there's 16.8 billion of them when
energy is absorbed that corresponds to
this transition we see it in the
spectrum
this is more quantum chemistry than you
had asked for i'm sorry no no i'm
sorry my brain is broken so when the
transitions happen between the different
states
uh somehow the energy maps the spectrum
exactly
energy corresponds to a frequency and a
frequency corresponds to a wavelength
which corresponds to a color
so there's some probability assigned to
each color then
exactly and that probability determines
how intense that transition will be
how strong and so you run this kind of
simulation for a particular
let's say that 17.5 squared or something
like that exactly
17.5 million energies each one of whom
involves diagonalizing a giant matrix
with a supercomputer
which i wonder what the most efficient
algorithm for that diagonalization is
but there there's some many depends on
kind of the
shape of the matrix so they're not
random matrixes so some are more
diagonal than others and
so some need more treatment than others
most of the work ends up going in
describing the system this quantum
system in different ways until you have
a matrix that is
close to being diagonal and then it's
much easier to
clean it up so how how many uh how hard
is this puzzle
so you're solving this puzzle for
phosphine right
um is this are we supposed to solve this
puzzle for every single
molecule oh boy yes i calculated if i
if i did the work i did for phosphine
again for all the molecules for which we
don't have
spectra for which we don't have a
fingerprint it would take me
62 000 years a little over 62 000 years
what time flies when you're having fun
okay but you uh
you write that there are about 16 000
molecules we care about
when looking for a new earth or when we
try to detect alien biosignatures
if we want to detect any molecules from
here we need to know their spectra
and we currently don't solving this
particular problem
that's my job where was that that i mean
that's absolutely correct
yeah i could have could have not said it
better myself did you take that from my
website yeah i think i
stole it and your website is excellent
so it's
worthy place to steal stuff from how do
you solve this problem
uh of for the 16 000 molecules we care
about
of which phosphine is one yes and so
um so taking a step a little bit out of
fossil
is there uh but we were having so much
fun
who's having so much fun no we're not
saying no no no it's sticking around
i'm just saying we're joining more
friends coming to the party
how do you choose other friends to come
to the party that are interesting to
study
as we solve one puzzle at a time through
the space of 16 000.
so we've already started out of those 16
000 we understand water quite well
methane quite well ammonia quite well
carbon dioxide i could keep going and
then we understand molecules like
acetylene
hydrogen cyanide more or less
and that takes us to about four percent
of those sixteen thousand
we understand about four percent of them
more or less phosphine is one of them
but the other 96 percent we just really
have
barely any idea at all of where in the
spectrum of light they would leave a
mark
i can't spend the next 62 000 years
doing this work
um and i don't want to even if you know
somehow i was able that
that's not that that wouldn't feel good
so one of the things that i try to do
now
is move away from how i did phosphene so
i did phosphine
really the best that i could the best
that could be done with the computer
power that we have
you know trying to get each one of those
16.8 billion transitions mapped
accurately calculated
and then i thought what if i do a worse
job
what if i just do a much worse job and
can i just make it much faster and then
it's still worth it
yes like how bad can i get
before it's worthless and then could i
do this
for all the other molecules so i created
exactly this terrible
terrible it's a system how about it so
how
what's the answer to that question that
fundamental question asked myself all
the time in other domains
how crappy can i be before i'm useless
before somebody notices
turns out pretty crappy because
no one has any idea what these molecules
look like
anything is better than nothing and so i
thought
how long will it take me to create
better than nothing spectra
for all of these molecules and so i
created rascal
rapid approximate spectral calculations
for all and
what i do is i use organic chemistry and
quantum chemistry
and kind of cheat at them both i just
try to figure out
what is the fastest way i could run this
and i simulate
rough spectra for all of those 16 000 so
i've managed to get it to work
it's really shocking how well it works
considering how bad it is
is there any insights you could give to
like the
the tricks involved in making it fast
like what are the
um maybe some insightful shortcuts taken
that still result in some useful
information about the spectra
the insights came from organic chemistry
from decades ago
when organic chemists wanted to know
what a compound might be they would look
at a spectrum
and see a feature and they would go i've
seen that feature before
that's usually what happens when you
have a carbon triple bonded
to another carbon and they were mostly
right almost every molecule that has a
carbon triple bonded to another one
looks like that has other features
different
that distinguish them from one another
but they have that that feature in
common
we call these functional groups and so
most of that work
ended up being abandoned because now we
have mass spectrometry we've got nuclear
magnetic resin spectroscopy so
people don't really need to do that
anymore
but these ancient textbooks still exist
and i've collected them
all as many as i could and there are
hundreds of these descriptions where
people have said
oh whenever you have a
iodine atom connected to this one
there's always a feature here and it's
usually quite sharp
and it's quite strong and some people go
oh yeah that's a really broad feature
every time that
combination of atoms and bonds so i've
collected them all
and i've created this giant dictionary
of all these kind of
puzzle pieces these lego parts of
molecules
and i've written a code that then puts
them all together in some kind of like
frankenstein's monster of molecules so
you ask me for any molecule and i go
well it has
these bonds and this atom dangling off
this atom
and this cluster here and i tell you
what it should look like
and it kind of works so this creates a
whole
portfolio of just kind of uh signatures
that we could look for
very rough temperatures but still useful
enough to analyze the atmospheres
the the telescope generated images of
of other planets close
right now it is so complete so it has
all of these molecules
that i can tell you say you look at an
alien atmosphere and there's a feature
there it can tell you oh that feature
that's familiar it could be one of these
816 molecules best of luck yes
so i think the next step which is what
i'm working on is telling you something
more useful than it could be one of
those 816 molecules that's still true
i wouldn't say it's useful so i can tell
you but only
12 of them also have a feature in this
region so go look there
and if there's nothing there it can't be
those and so on
it can also tell you things like you
will need this much accuracy to
distinguish between those 816.
so that's what i'm working on but it's a
lot of work
so this is really interesting the like
the role of computing in this whole
picture you mentioned code
so like you as a quantum
astrochemist there is some role
of for programming in your life in your
past life in your current life
oh yeah almost entirely i'm a
computational quantum astrochemist
but that doesn't roll off the tongue
very easily so this is fundamentally
computational
like if you want to be successful in the
21st century in doing quantum master
chemistry you want to be computational
absolutely all quantum chemistry is
computational at this point okay
what uh does uh machine learning play a
role at all
is there some extra shortcuts that could
be discovered through
uh like you see all that success with
protein folding
right a problem that thought to be
extremely
difficult to apply machine learning to
because
it's um
i mean mostly because there's not a lot
of already
solved puzzles to train on i suppose the
same
exact thing is true with this particular
problem but is there hope for machine
learning to help out
absolutely currently you've laid out
exactly the problem
the training set is awful
and because there's so a lot of this
data that i'm basing it on is literally
many decades old
the people who worked on it and data
that i get often they're dead
and um the files that i've used they
some of them were hand drawn by someone
tired in the 70s
yes so i could of course have yeah have
a
program training on these but i would
just be perpetuating these mistakes
without hope
of actually verifying them so my next
step is to
improve this training set by hand
and then try to see if i can apply
machine learning on the full code of the
full 16 000 molecules
and improve them all but really i need
to be able to test the outcomes with
experimental data which means convincing
someone
in a lab to spend a lot of money putting
very dangerous
gases in chambers and measuring them at
outrageous temperatures so it's a work
in progress
and so collecting huge amounts of data
about the actual gases
uh so you see you so you
you are up for doing that kind of thing
too so
actually like doing the full
end to end thing which is like having a
gas collecting
data about it and and then doing the
kind of analysis that creates the
fingerprint
and then also analyzing using that
library the data that comes from other
planets
so you do the full fall from birth to
death
interesting um yes i worked in an
industrial chemistry laboratory when i
was
much younger in slovenia and there i
worked in the lab
actually collecting spectrum and
predicting spectrum
what's it like to work with a bunch of
gases that are like not so human
friendly
it's terrifying it's horrific it's so
scary
and i love my job i'm willing to clearly
sacrifice a lot for it
you know job stability money
yes sanity but
i only worked there for a few months it
it was really terrifying
there's just so many ways to die you
know usually you only have a handful of
ways to die every day you know but
if you work in a lab there's so many
more orders of magnitude more
and i i was very bad at it i'm not a
good
hands-on scientist i want a laptop
connected to a remote supercomputer or a
laptop connected to a telescope
yes i don't i don't need to be there to
believe it
and i am not good in the lab yeah when
there's a bunch of things that can
poison you a bunch of things that could
explode and they're gaseous and they're
often
maybe they might not even have a smell
or they might not be visible
it's like so many of them give you
cancer it's just so cruel
and some people love this work but i've
i've never enjoyed experimental work
it's so ungrateful
it's so lonely well most i mean so much
work is lonely
if you find the joy in it but you you
enjoy the results of it
yes i'm very thankful for all the
experimentalists in my life
but i i'll do the theory they do the
experiment and then we talk to one
another and make sure it matches
uh okay beautiful what are uh
spectroscopic networks those look super
cool are they related to what we were
talking about
the pictures look pretty oh and yes
slightly
so remember when i mentioned the 17.5
million energy levels
yes there are rules for each molecule on
which
energy levels they can jump from and to
and how likely it is to make that jump
and so
if you plot all the routes it can take
you get this energy network for
which is like a ball so these are the
constraints of the
the transitions that could be taken
exactly for each molecule
interesting and no they're not so it's
not a fully connected
it's like it's it's sparse somehow yes
you get island sometimes you get
a molecule can only jump from one set of
states to another and it's trapped now
in this network it can never go to
another network
that could have been available to other
siblings
is there some incidents to be drawn from
these networks like something
cool that you can understand about a
particular molecule because of it
yes some molecules have what we call
forbidden transitions
um which aren't really forbidden because
it's quantum there are no rules no
there are rules it's just the rules are
very often broken in the quantum world
and so forbidden transitions doesn't
actually mean they're forbidden
low probability exactly they just become
deeply unlikely
yeah cool and so you could do all the
same like i'm
coming from a computer science world you
know i love graph theory
so you can do all the same like graph
theoretic kind of analysis
of like clusters or something like that
or all those kinds of things
and draw insights from it very unique
for each molecule
so these the networks that you mentioned
that's actually not too difficult a
layer of quantum physics
by then all the energies are mapped so
we've had
high school children work on those
networks and the trick is to not tell
them they're doing quantum physics until
like three months in when it's too late
for them to back out
and then you're like you're a quantum
physicist now and it's really nice
you